this side of the room first so I said
nothing sexual we're witches
went whenever my wife has a yeast
infection is the phrase she uses nothing
sexual Chris it's not happening for at
least a week three days if she's had
some cranberry juice so I don't know
whether that Joe was gross oh you just
go oh he has a wife with so yeast
infection blamed this man for that this
side of the room this little wedge here
what will once what was that air jordans
okay cool air jordans yeast infection
this rectangle here Game of Thrones gets
shout out all the time I'm afraid so I
don't take the same suggestions twice
one second I
I wish you'd shatter that louder and no
one had heard that what was what was the
thing you said after Game of Thrones
urban archery will be taken that but you
said redshift of space yeah thank you
very much for you awful person
okay so yeast infection urban archery
the redshift of space which I'm sure
will figure out what it is at some point
what was the other one from over here
Air Jordans and what were you showing
so I'll be honest with you that has been
suggested here before and it would be
meaning me to take it against I'll be
cheating so I won't say that what was
the other one no that way what's a hand
up here you Rubik's Cube has been
suggested before I've done Sally's
elevator wonderful yeah cool I can tell
you that that so it means not being
suggested before that seems fair so Air
Jordans elevator redshift of space urban
archery in yeast infection don't you
look him so proud of that just that yeah
in shows to come you're gonna be saying
the best suggestion you ever had was
Easter infection 9th century yeast
infection know this then lovely people
of the comedy of magic club to close out
your night is a little thing called a
freestyle rap there's a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions and do not worry it'll not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as you are expecting
it to be never have I seen a room of
people so unconvinced or something they
just say do you want to drop that beat
you know tell you about redshift of
space about yeast infection about air
jordans urban archery and and elevators
it's gonna be cool use very much a night
excite for this but that's that's
alright
make up as a goal I take a risk I never
use the scares yeah I'll always take a
lift elevate a catchy lair get to the
top floor when you're on the Empire
State yeah right drop jaws I've never
seen it gara feel thrilling I arrived up
the lift on the Chrysler Building why we
say left in the UK but elevators what
you say confuses me yeah I'll never be a
hater confuse it with an escalator there
the stairs the move is just a syllable
difference everybody right now quite
diffident they're confused in a drink
because apart be I here right in the
central artery I never do it in the
countryside I want to do it in an urban
genocide I'm like showing all the people
in the suits on Wall Street I first aim
at their legs and the small feet and
then I go right up to the target hit
them in the shirts bought from Target
and where the heart is that's a little
blade put it in the flesh got the notch
that I made I know all the archery lingo
and gold out in Mexico yeah I'm a gringo
when I'm firing all the arrows like
Robin Hood I'll be stealing lots of
money ever I'm Robin Hood probably look
at astrology you know I should maybe get
more knowledge and derma hood talk about
how in this place we see a different
spectrum the light from space comes
through he removes the collection she
approves about word that's a spectrum
move over the Erica resist move it we
call that term redshift it's why the
light shines redder light in my country
we say Shepards to life I don't know why
we say that again maybe please this the
only Shepherd who's delightful would be
Jesus probably yes tick in the head and
let me tell you if you're wipe when the
paper was read it could be a yeast
infection or an STI I don't know you
should just blame this guy horrible the
one that I like the least why would you
want a freestyle about yeast if it
doesn't make sense he's sick in the head
is like a Jenna alder looks like bread
because it's giving off the scent like a
bakery lasting watch for fakery I go
down to a little market Frank and nice
pair of sneakers start here bartering
haggling with the guy on the stall I see
I need a pair of pumps to play
basketball he comes up to me he says of
least a rapport you like these sneakers
they
for sport they're amazing yeah you
really will adore them if you're like
Space Jam these are Air Jordans
Michael's people bike fulfill my Nike 23
triples I invite you to try a model my
life was complete I've got a big foot
here I've got large feet I need to get
him on and I gave respect I liked the
support on the midsole around the instep
these aren't Air Jordans though that was
just a mind you got a picture the
sneakers in your mind yet
[Music]
[Applause]